okay
foreign
all right folks uh good morning and
welcome to this extraordinary council
meeting
to consider some papers around the three
Waters reform
before we get into
um
the more formal side of it just for me
to signal to Aaron that I am in
opposition to this being in PE
Public Schools so before we move there I
would like some explanation for that the
rationale being that we've been required
by Dia and the minister for more than
three years now to not consult with our
community this documents are very
important one as we transition to
the new entity that's being proposed and
for the community to be kept in the dark
about this specially given the uh
um opposition there is from the staff
paper around the bun around the
financial implications I just think
can't be wanted so I guess I'll
colleagues and for staff signaling that
I'm in opposition 2pe or alternatively
um I would be open to be in PE but to
really support the moment the meetings
first
okay
I have your view on that would be
helpful I guess here before we do yes so
um around the uh submission
um as I discussed with Michael there's
no reason why we can't release the
submission
um after this meeting the difficulty
with holding the entire meeting in open
forum is that the information from DIA
is released to staff on the basis that
it is to be held confidential and you'll
see in the submission that we have Inc
the view of staff and and that may be
the view of elected members was that a
consultation process should be run on
this however at the moment staff are in
the position of being instructed by Dia
to keep the process confidential at this
stage so if I am allowing staff to
continue with that sure
so we'll come back to that in a minute
I'll just do some some housekeeping to
start with um
and to acknowledge that we've got Doug
uh Tom zooming in and we've got an
apology from Alex and would somebody
like to move that we accept a major late
item which is a three-water transition
program update
yes thank you
and thank you grant about that all those
in favor
oh sorry and I also need to accept the
apology from Alex
Leslie thank you grant all those in
favor all right carried
so coming back to your point I mean
um
while we're still on open I just cannot
get my mind around my Dia give us
information about our reform which is at
least three years possibly three and a
half years in the making
and how we can have major opposition to
the financial implications which is huge
for us and they give us information on
you they give us information about our
Council on the assumption that it's held
in confidence and I'd like some
discussion about what will happen if we
breach that in confidence provision from
DIA
if you can help me with that
I'm not going to probably provide
instruction on that I would leave that
to our legal counsel which I expect we
may want to take away unless Michael has
a comment at this stage
and now through your yourself mere
at this this point we haven't had a had
a chance to actually review from a legal
sense uh what the ramifications would be
should we breach that so I'd ask that
we'd be have the opportunity to take
that away and review that before coming
back
so I'll come back in on my ring you so
again from my perspective
three and a half years in the making
this report was given to me late last
night
um to consider it overnight is just
diabolical it's given that such a huge
issue now let's not reflect on staff I
understand the criteria that you're
working under asking us to do this work
within five days it's just a disaster
from a government perspective I can't
understand why there's the urgency
because look the bottom line is if labor
gets back in it will work its way
through this process anyway
um if National gets in they've said
already said publicly they'll repeal the
ACT so why is the urgency to get it done
before election time and it seems to me
they just don't want it to be an
election football
but from our end we've got major
concerns
we're given less than 12 hours to think
about it
and then we hide it away in the PE so
nobody in the community knows what we're
agreeing or disagreeing to
and on I've got a quite a bit to raise
in this report as I work my way through
a lot of issues for me
um nobody in the public gets to hear it
because the DI doesn't want out in the
public
foreign
oh yes sorry Tom yeah
let me ask a a question which I guess is
one to
um Michael
um the fact that we received a document
from a third party
who asks us to keep it confidential does
that actually change our oil obligation
with respect to whoever something should
be held in public at Hilton public
excluded depended on the rules with
again surely the fact that the third
party has provided the document has
asked for it to be held and
private does not change your obligation
so quite simply put
um Mr Mayor the answer to that is Our
obligation is always first and foremost
to the provisions of lagoima
um while there isn't it if there's
something a document is provided with an
expectation of confidentiality then
legume does provide for that but it is
still our ultimate decision on whether
it meets the logoma tests including the
ultimate logon matist is it still within
the public interest
and just to reinforce what you see of
Tom when you look at the the grid that
we've got in front of us for the reason
for going into public excludes it states
um Carry Out commercial activities and
conduct and and conduct conduct not
contract conduct negotiations well I
don't see any commercial uh data in this
report it's just asking us to respond on
the
uh on the uh
into the Jag and the impact for our city
um and it says completion of negations
negotiations well I don't see any
negotiations in this document with Dia
or the national transition unit with the
exception that we want to make a
submission to the select committee
um
so
rang in Indiana yeah thank you Mr Mayor
look you're right I think I think we've
got our obligation is to conform to the
ACT and from what Michael was saying
um the reasons given by the DIA don't
conform with the ACT uh they are pushing
it you did right there are known to go
negotiations we are just being told what
to do there has been that way all the
lot all the time and I'll take you back
to July
2021 July the 15th actually at the local
government conference in Blenheim and I
sat there in the hall with everyone else
and there's a certain prime minister
stood up in front of us and said that
this reform is coming but every Council
will have the ability to opt-in or opt
out that's like my word on that okay
that was great so we put our submissions
in in October 2021 and staff took a lot
of time to do that and then what happens
oh sorry it's now compulsory so how
based on those facts and what we've
learned
why are we treating this with with the
respect that they're trying to get get
out of us it doesn't make any sense they
deserve no respect the way they've
treated us so I'd be quite open to to
have this in public yeah
Peter did you wish to say
um okay at the moment
okay
anybody else like to discuss the issue
of PE versus non-pe
yeah Leslie
I think Darren was first what's up
he's defaulting to you Lucy ah okay I
was just going to say as far as I'm
concerned we should be taking the advice
of our legal person on this until then
public excluded is where it should sit
I'm not sure that's the advice he gave
us but them on Darren essentially my
position was the same it was the advice
was there was no advice at this point of
time that they would need to take time
to get some and until we've had that
considered advice I don't think we could
move into open
well
I'll I'll move a motion somewhere online
on this issue but just just as a
reflection look this has to go today
we don't have a chance to go away into
the back room and get some legal advice
hence we're here first thing in the
morning
um
and I've had to read the report
overnight if you've been lucky enough to
do that
um
so we don't have an ability to go off
and get some illegal advice without
makeup decision that we're going to have
this one open
or we're not going to have no Grant
yeah thanks Mr me um
yeah so what what are the implications
for us
in terms of so what I heard Michael say
was that through laguama we can actually
decide to have a it in public is that
correct or did I misinterpret what you
said so Our obligation is through
and how we decide to conduct our
business yeah when you receive
information that is sent to us on an
Express expectation of confidence yes
and it is incumbent on Council to
respect that yes um I haven't had a
chance uh nor Andrew have had a chance
to actually go through this and what
would be the consequences for us if we
were to breach that expectation from DIA
um but ultimately it is your decision as
counselors as to whether you receive an
item and pay you or not it is the staff
obligation and that's what Aaron and
Andrew have done yeah is that they've
said this is the expectation from the
Department
um
and ultimately I think we've hit and
maintained a good working relationship
with the Department throughout this
issue and I believe that we would want
to maintain that working relationship
with the Department putting aside the
ultimate political Masters above them
yeah but but there's another source of
that around the public interest which is
ultimately what we're responsible as a
council for isn't it yeah so an
ultimately
is where even if there is a reason for
getting it in public excluded or and
often not releasing something that has
to make as it or otherwise in the
interests of the public for it to be
released yeah and so if if asses council
is decided to ignore the request from
DIA
we're not compromising staff in any way
because we've decided as counselors and
elected members in the interests of
public
to make a decision to go public with it
versus
um you know
staff being at risk so as with all
matters that are political decisions
they are political decisions you have
received staff advice and then you as
the council laws as the politicians make
the decision that
you Dean yeah so if we choose to go
public we're in effect that's on Earth
it's our decision as opposed to you know
putting stuff in the foreign line with
DOI because we've in effect overruled
the advice we've been given more stuff
yes but staff will live with those
consequences
any damage to the relationship with the
DIA that they may not be as forthcoming
with information so so what sort of
damage would that be again um that would
be me trying to delve into what this
information is and I can't do that on
the hoof and I'm not prepared to no but
that will be on as a general point that
would be the damage that I would expect
to come
I've got a couple of other speakers good
point you raise ground
um the one of the key things in here is
the cost of our Waters going forward
yeah that's right yeah if we stand alone
and if
um if we're part of entity J and the
device we've got from staff in this
paper is absolutely clear that the
figures given by Dia are flawed this is
not the first time we've raised it or I
go back a year and a half two years ago
we had the same information up Michael's
here I remember having discussions with
him about that it just falls on deaf
ears I went to Parliament to select
committee and made the same submission
one person across the room with me and
the rest were zooming in it was fastable
didn't get any response after that about
the issue that your figures are wrong so
at what stage do you just keep doing
this
and then one day it will blow up with
them with our media or with our
committee and we've just been complicit
all the way through so yeah yeah Michael
thank you through yourself Mia
the information that there we're
suggesting
um remain within um PE is information
about the entities
Etc that's been provided by the DIA
that's not just affecting the DIA that's
affecting all of the other councils that
are within the entity because their
information is included in there as well
um it's normal when you're doing a
commercial negotiation from this
perspective which we would argue it's
not necessarily a commercial negotiation
um that all parties involved would need
to sign off on release of information
from that perspective and we haven't got
that from any of the parties at this
point but having said that that is only
in the information to inform Council
about the entity the submission itself
um as we we've suggested we would look
to proactively release it immediately
following
um there is another way that council
could conduct this meeting to have an
open discussion is to discuss the
submission openly
um but to retain the other information
and PE that is one way to do it but that
would require to go in and out of PE
but that is an option available to
council that's something guns would like
to do
two things I'd love to see the actual
formal letter or email from the DIA
actually asking us to keep this out and
actually look at the wording and the
other thing is what exact Parts Michael
um are showing off
other councils private information
yeah I mean you're talking in that last
oh
um but which we don't really need to see
the Crux is in the submission and in our
own council's bullet point thing really
and then the debate around it the rest
of it is support that are you talking
about the Roadshow effectively
information well the road shows
Superfluous to what we're basically
talking about today I actually see it as
um apart from the font being too small
um yeah I mean if it was a way of
removing that that appendix on the
Roadshow you're all it would be good to
go then is that right well there is one
there is one part in the Roadshow which
is the predicted cost going forward if
we are Standalone as opposed to being an
entity J and then we've had those
information already in there yeah that's
part of our submission too
report
s Michael's got that in the report that
in our submission but he doesn't nail it
down so the assessment locally is that
our costs will be about 1800 and and the
government's saying it'll be probably
twice that amount yeah so
that's the only bit that we need to link
yeah
yeah Tom and then Evelyn
um
it seems to me that we're trying to
judge between a document which is in my
view of extreme public interest yeah
against uh a request by the DIA which
seems to me when I look at it as a
request it just wants this full thing to
slip through the keeper with public
screw it any yeah um it's difficult to
see any other reason for it I hear but
make will just see the private
information from other councils but I
agree right now that there's nothing
much in there that I can see that would
be that would be considered you know not
already in the public
Arena
um if a motion came forward to
um hear this in public I would
personally support it and the basis that
clearly this is of extreme public
interest particularly in invercargill
probably more than anywhere else in the
country because of the negative
implications for for us of the um of
this direction
yeah thanks for that Evelyn
um
in principle
I think already
some of what has been said is actually
prejudiced the in committee I could be
wrong about that but we're having
discussion now
um which is sort of talking about things
that actually should be exploded under
the information
I think we need to be really careful it
isn't just our information that's in
yeah it is other people's and is that
normally
and my understanding of professional
practice is when you do take things
public excluded because it's not just
our information if it was only this
City's information there wouldn't be a
problem if it's other people's
information we have no right we don't
have the information we should not be
discussing
anything that could lead to disclosing
the business of other entities and I
think
are not sure
quite how I feel about this but there is
also the people who are potentially
doing the work on entityj and their
right for protection and as well now we
don't know who they are well some people
in this room may do but I don't
but their interests need to be at our at
the front of our minds because they're
innocent bystanders in all of this in
terms of anything that we might say or
do today
I think see it it is of interest to
public in general but if we haven't got
our
fixed right if we haven't been able to
frankly canvas our opinions then we're
actually doing our thinking out loud in
public and perhaps saying things that
are unwise so
um not that I get a vote on this matter
but I would be far more comfortable if I
were a voting Governor that it went into
committee we discussed it as freely as
we could and make our decision about
what we release coming out of it whilst
we are in committee and having an
informed
reasoned
answer coming out
thank you
as I understand it's a request to
um not release this information or to
keep it in committee
how binding is that request
as opposed to saying You must
so I haven't seen the exact routing from
the DIA but I I don't believe staff
would have made the request and put it
into public excluded unless they felt
that they were that was an obligation
that they should honor okay thank you
oh
damn
thanks
um I I think we've already made
a really good point about the process
and and about the fact that there is
exceptional public interest and about
the fact that Dia haven't
really given us not really haven't given
us
um a great deal of time to respond and
and digest
um that that Point's been well made and
and I could well guess the headlines
already written
I don't agree with us releasing
information that's that's not ours but I
absolutely have no problem with us
releasing our submission uh and and for
that because that is information that is
ours but it would be
I understand the sentiment behind
wanting to have it all out there but
we can't have the information that we
don't have control over being released
because we've decided it should be
because perhaps Dia could have run a
better process that's that's just poor
form so while I support our submission
being in public I don't support the
discussion and the release of that
information at this point
uh thank you Miss Mia I was going to say
exactly what Darren's just said so I
support that completely
okay
Peter yeah thank you Mr Mia
look over the years
um
us and previous Council
have built up probably one of the best
three Water Systems in the country
the value of air through water system is
really there's six months ago
543 million dollars
there's a huge public interest in this
and we could have a lot to lose so I
would definitely want to the public to
hear what we're talking about and have
this discussion in Open Session thank
you
so just as a final reflection for me
from those that weren't here last term
about two or two and a half years ago
there was a lot of pressure on us and
other councils to release information
around three Waters
minister at the time
um gave us a commitment as the
department did that we should hold off
and not do that and they were going to
give us a um I guess a set of
information that we could use that was
unique to invocable you know it varies
from one Council to the other how this
will impact and we were told and told
and told it was coming and we never got
it
um and this just seems to me that this
is getting pushed through it at the
legislative level without any
consultation and it's like cliche
um I guess the easiest way to resolve
this oh sorry another thing I'd say is
we've given a commit to the Kim
community and this Council has to be
transparent on major issue this is the
biggest issue we'll face in the next
well the last five years and depending
on how quickly resource management comes
around
um this is huge
um for us when you look into the data
there and the DIA information which they
don't want us to release is that we if
we stand alone will be 3 800 and the
advice from Patricia and Michael is it's
actually two thousand dollars a year
Less on that that is a major in
discretion that we have to be able to
resolve and we can't do that by doing
things and quietly behind the closed
doors with the national transition unit
so the way to resolve this is and I'll
just ask somebody to take the
recommendation for which is to move into
a public excluded and and if that's
defeated then we'll stay and open
somebody like to move that we go into
into PE or sorry Trish
you're moving we go into PE
seconded by there
um helpful to have a show of hands now
so there's no confusion about who's
yelling out the most all those favorites
moving into public exclude session
raise your hands
one two three four five
and those opposed
one two three
four five and Tom sorry and Tom's
opposed as well six so the vote goes
against moving it into public scooter
and we will save on live live stream
could have my favorite recorded please
certainly yes we've got all that
appendix one the Roadshow supporting
content that being is just confirming is
that the sensitive information
well that's what it said that has
information about other things okay I
mean and that is only available to us on
our board books and may potentially come
up on the big screen is that right
the intention would be for that to come
up on the big screen and Michael can
advise that uh Michael Morris that if we
are in public now whether all of the
contents of the report need to be
released publicly
yeah I'm just asking the Mia um if
you know they would be that I mean to me
that Roadshow stuff is is doesn't have
any substance in it at all compared to
the main issue so the only two things in
here I see is the grid about
what it will cost going forward and the
other thing is it declares that waitaki
is no longer an entity J okay well your
your submission uh gives us Clarity on
what cost is going forward
fromvercargill
um and that's contained in there so if
if we can omit public display of that uh
Roadshow
what's on the agenda no no no I mean on
the big screen we've got agenda you if
you're going to take it in public and
the agenda is a public document what are
you what what's the debate about oh no
I'm just asking well okay hang on I'll
clarify the situation yeah and I'll call
an adjournment for five minutes
and all allow stuff and anybody else
interested to quickly flick through the
uh stuff that's provided by da and give
me a heads up on anything that you think
is commercially sensitive to another
Council because I can't see that while
you're reading all the documents
so I've got five minutes
[Music]
so the position from staff for elected
members is that they are uncomfortable
about talking to the slides which is the
first part of the presentation so that
will probably be presented as a
um
presented to us on the basis that we've
read it
um the advice from DIA is that they
still want to commercially sensitive and
not released clearly we've moved to do
the opposite so I'll either put I'll
wear any Flack that comes over that and
then staff will talk us through the
submission that's the latter part of
that but it doesn't stop us going
through the uh the slides to start with
which doesn't mean that they have to be
particularly up there but you've got the
on-board books and we've got it in hard
copy for those that have got hard copy
because there's clearly some stuff that
I need to discuss about the slides as we
go forward with the staff as well so
they understand we're elected members
are coming from
so uh
I guess the first thing at first the
recommendation on that is to uh
acknowledge the report if somebody would
like to move that way
Barry and ring thank you any discussion
about accepting the report
excellent well there's a favor
and the second part is denote the
contents which I should have done at the
same time yeah
very interesting all those in favor
and I'll leave that the final one which
is the um bit about approving the
submission to
um
submission to the water services bills
Amendment bill because I guess process
wise we may not agree with the
submission so just work our way through
that so Aaron if you'd like to walk us
through just the tabling of the slides
and we can then have some discussion
about that
so in terms of the tabling of the slides
stuff will withdraw the slides from the
report and simply leave the submission
um standing on the table
let's leave the submission put forward
for consideration
uh probably need some advice from
Michael on this uh I guess if you
withdraw it where's our ability to
discuss some of the issues that are in
it which actually supports submission
that you've got going forward so if the
slides are withdrawn they don't form
part of the uh report going forward or
the staff presentation that limits
councilor's ability to put questions
around the slides but it is information
that you have received staff can't
answer directly anything in relation to
those
okay Tom
sorry I mean obviously I I never quite
hear the discussion during the recess
but I mean just here in that comment as
it was made there I mean it seems to be
as little staff are frustrating The Well
of council
by deciding to that they will not answer
questions that will not present slice
despite the fact that counselor decided
there would be here general public
um I find that extraordinary but even if
the slides are withdrawn Schumer the
fact that it is now being built in
public those slides are going to be made
public they can't I mean they are surely
they are already public
not if they're withdrawn
there's the slides and so I'm sure you
Mr chair the slides
um and part of report staff have the
ability to withdraw any part of a report
if they need
um
and that is what has occurred in this
occasion it doesn't mean that you can't
ask questions about it
um it's information that you have read
it would be foolish to try and stop that
but staff are limited on what they can
respond to because those slides would no
longer form part of
they report
sure
the purpose of this being held in public
um Forum
um the conscious decision by Council to
do so because we wish that Kent the
public do have that information then if
the slaves are not to be sure enough to
be published it might be that
um you if nobody else will do it should
just reduce some of the important parts
that included most likes those those
things that we do believe that public
should be aware of such as the cost
yep thanks for the advice Tom and that
was clearly my intention anyway so I'll
accept that I'm not going to compromise
stuff
yeah I just note that we do have an
upcoming infrastructure committee
meeting we may be in a position where we
could have legal advice my only concern
is around I don't think we're clear yet
whether or not you would actually put
staff legally in the firing line
um through that whether or not Council
can actually take that responsibility
away from staff so all I would say is
that you're potentially putting stuff at
risk we don't know that yet we could get
some advice and look to bring the that
the content of the slides back for
discussion at infrastructure committee
may be an option for consideration well
my response to that is we've already
decided that it will be held in public
if staff don't want to comment for
reasons of they feel compromised or
their relationship with the national
transition unit is compromise or they
breach the conditions that they thought
they were under from that unit that's
fine I don't have any problems with that
but that doesn't solve our elected
members
Barry just sorry point of order yes sir
nucleation is now that Aaron has raised
formerly raised the issue of Staff being
put formally at legal risk uh the fact
that if we discuss issues within the
slides I think
um
that puts a different light on it the
fact that we've been formally warned
um of the legal risk to start personally
now I can't understand it but I don't
need to understand it I've just been
told that now it makes me uncomfortable
and the fact that that statement's been
made and to proceed
along those lines even though I agree
totally with the transparency and this
is of everything but once you start
using terms like legally at risk
we've just raised the stakes Beyond us
um trying to do what's right for the
public so there's two issues at stake
here and there's no way that I would be
prepared to compromise
staff legally there's no way there's no
way sorry if that obviously Aaron
wouldn't say it if it wasn't real so
um it makes me uncomfortable now
that information wasn't available to us
before we made that decision
well I guess as Tom has already alluded
it it undermines a good slice of
democracy when a paper is tabled here
for us to consider at 12 hours notice a
very significant document I might add as
huge implications going forward
um we've asked for information about
why they say that our
if we're in the ncj our you know if we
stood away if we could stand away from
enter DJ our reach going forward in the
next 10 years or whatever it was would
be 3 800 with the advice we get from our
finance people is it is actually only
eighteen hundred dollars and we've
raised this before and we continue to
raise it and we don't get a response so
at what stage do we say and that's
enough yeah but my point is that one of
the fundamentals of of and the actors
that Council which is US must be good
employers and and if we in some way
um put our staff at legal personal legal
risk then I think that is not being a
good employer sorry I've just I mean
that's as well I understand that but at
what stage do we just have no further
discussion on the slides and we just
take the paper given that some the paper
is a response to the slide to my dad
and this significant about support in
those two documents but we just won't
talk about what the nias are in into you
put up
um because they have an ability to talk
to staff and to keep this all wrapped up
well we've got an obligation to our
community as well
I'll take your advice a minute Michael
on this
oh sorry Tom
I was just going to ask the question
whether
paper when it was really
um
to I'll use the word council was it
released only to staff or was it
released to stop and cancel because if
it was released in fourth if it was
released for an expectation of become
Council then I don't see how staff would
have any legal liability if Council
decided to
um release that I mean if it was only
released to staff then I take the point
but if it's released it must stop and
cancel and cancel make that decision I
think it is difficult to understand how
that's going to result in any legal
um
you know anything that's could legally
be charged and stuff
I mean I take the point and I take
Ryan's point that we would never want
that to happen I just it just seems to
be such a long board to draw
so my question is telling me a question
my question is was it always with
expectation a bit of a couple of council
if it was and Council make a resolution
ever reset
um
you know Leslie is a lawyer this was
Michael and I mean it just seems to be
an awful awful lot what you try to say
then staff can get any some kind of
legal trouble over it
I'll leave you to give some thought to
that Michael
any further discussions
Barry yeah I'm I'm
amazed at the they'll dump a piece of
paper on us 12 years before we come here
and it's just another indication from
this government they really just don't
care
um
October's here
uh Ria Mr me thank you
um on reflection since we've been here
this morning listening to the back and
forward I'm off the um concern that we
have a clear directive request to our
staff through the document they received
that parts of this information is to be
kept confidential we have Tango back and
forward seeking
um answers from our staff they have told
us that they will potentially be legally
held responsible for
breaching that condition and my concern
is that
we have a situation where we can have
the submission discussed in public but
keep the slides relative to that
commercial sensitivity out of it
um now I've been happy with that
directive yes it may not meet all of our
needs in terms of how we deal with it
today but nevertheless this submission
has to be in by tomorrow night at 11 59.
so
when are we going to agree to a due
process to make sure we keep the staff
safe and we can do our job so and and I
I will ask shortly where we get this
opinion that uh Snapper at risk because
going back about two years ago a year
and a half ago two years ago we got the
exact same thing from the minister and
from DIA not to go public and rang you
will recall the meeting that
um that we we had a vote that we didn't
go because the dis was not to go so we
hung out why makariri on the other hand
said no enough's enough and they went
out publicly
and it created a real storm in their
Community 95 of the of the submitters
said we don't want three Waters
um but there was no legal implication
for waimakar area other than the fact
that they then were co-partners on
setting up the alternative group to
local government New Zealand
so
I understand that so I just need some
clarity about how we're putting um
putting staff at risk
either from a staff or from Michael
told us already
oh Leslie yes I think there
okay
I have a concern that
at this point
it's really bad form for us to be
criticizing staff in that manner if if
they have concerns and I understand that
people would like
some elaboration on why those concerns
exist that they have been pointed out
and there's some subjective listening
going on here that I'm loathed to go
against it
um
I still think that councilors in the
position of being a judge during
executioner for everybody else's
information and that's not comfortable
my the point is that the reason I raised
my hand is if we have a deadline and we
are able to signal that we have a
submission that's going to be made
what are the impacts of saying that we
signal that's coming and it arrives five
six days later
okay thanks that Leslie
then it doesn't thank you sorry could I
get a response to that question
you'd have to run the risk of the
submission not being accepted you can
ask and request for an extension for
extreme circumstances I think this would
be considered extreme of the minister
um
you're taking that risk
what I was going to say in the main part
of my
um request to speak is that
I think there is absolutely no point at
all in putting any staff member on spot
to to ask for a legal decision at this
moment that's staff and in particular
Michael and I myself have indicated this
is not a matter on which there can be a
sudden legal decision there actually
needs to be some time taken Michael's
indicated as our Council lawyer that
that time needs to be taken so I think
asking for a sudden decision or a sudden
explanation of why Staff feel they are
being put at risk from a legal
perspective is not a reasonable request
there is a reasonable way we could
proceed here because we are already at
20 past nine and we're not even in
discussion on the submission
it would still be possible for Council
to agree to take appendix one in
committee and appendix 2 in public
that would be a way to actually get this
discussion proceeding forward rather
than sitting here around the table
entering further into a discussion on
whether or not staff had legitimate
concerns
about the position at the current time
if Council would agree to take appendix
one in committee and appendix 2
in public we would be able to proceed
excuse me I I suggested that before that
was shot down that we couldn't do it so
I want to either either gonna be
consistent or not from the corner over
there yep
ground so if we if we do that
subsequently
can we release appendix one
um you know
so get some opinion to ensure staff are
protected and then release it
so we can take discussion on the paper
on appendix 2 we can submit it in the
time frames acknowledging and it's not
the star's fault that this has come late
to us I mean this is what's been you
know the staff are completely abdicated
in my view they've done a great job and
they've been put under huge pressure by
forward process but that's my opinion
um but
yeah so if we and then release appendix
um one
post it's some later date yep so it
still becomes public and the interest of
democracy but it doesn't hold us up in
the process and the risk air submission
being not accepted
um by the minister
I'm not sure the letter would be the
case but never mind um
so I guess we've got a couple of options
here well I've got some options I can
just call this meeting to an end until
we get some clarification from the
minister or Dia about that now that will
breach the deadline which is today
tomorrow yep that's one option the other
option is that we just don't consider um
one which is the slides if that's the
case we'll need to move some motions to
do that and then we just discuss the
paper that's going forward and release
it in later stage through one of the
Committees I'm open to that
and I'll need some advice from Michael
about how we given the fact that we've
gone into public on this how we then not
discuss the slides
sorry to put you on the spot again
thank you Mr Mayor so you would to do
that letter option
you would simply need to focus in on the
submission
um you I mean the reality is you've all
read appendix one it would as I said it
would be foolish not to expect you not
to ask some questions that come from
that even if you tried it will just
simply happen but Starfall in their
responses be able to set up that's
information contained in appendix one
appendix one can then potentially be
brought forward to the next
infrastructure committee meeting uh next
week
that hopefully will have given everybody
a chance to uh work out what information
uh is in there that can be released and
what information is in there that would
still need a level of um
uh reduction for that to be released it
would give that time for Andrew Cameron
and I to actually have a look at any or
in all of those legal implications
and also give time for staff to get the
information back we need from DIA in
their units about uh their views and
positions on that but it also means that
your um submission will go through
within the time frame
and Grant yeah just further things
specifically because there's two parts
to a phoenix one right there's the start
of the staff are prepaid via view of the
commentary around it and then there's
the information from DIA which is the
Roadshow isn't it yeah so
my
wish would be that
we we would release the information that
the staff have prepared what supports
the submission we're putting
I don't see this too much in there
that's sensitive
and then the Dia's Roadshow piece we may
get some clarification on and then
release it through
the infrastructure committee because I
think it's really important that our
community if we're going to do release
public
there's a submission the public needs to
see how we've come to that submission
and I think the slides that the staff
are prepared we support that and that
needs to be in the full lord of the
public in in association with their
submission so I'm not sure if you've got
a view on that era or Michael but if we
could somehow separate the two
avoid that those slides that the staff
prepared and supported the submission I
think we should look to do that because
it gives full of view of what exactly
we're talking about here
Aaron or Martin
I think they okay
I I understand
um the desire to do that I think the
difficulty that we have is that we
haven't prepared this on the basis of
the front stuff being public and then
the back stuff not being and so it'd be
a matter of us that now very quickly
trying to go through this and figuring
out what was out of the legislation and
what was out of the information provided
directly to us which would just be
difficult on the spot
okay
we don't want to be his lunch alone so
um
I'll just rule that we go down the track
that on the advice that Michael Morris
gave us that we don't discuss the slides
at the stage it goes forward to the
infrastructure committee but you can
refer to where you need to without
specifically referring because there are
a couple of issues there for us to
consider one is the issue of the cost
of
um
our water services going forward that
seems to be clearly a sore for us it's
been there for a couple of years and we
continue to challenge that and don't get
any response
and the second issue is the issue of
the into the J now only has seven
councils not eight so waitaki is not
there so what constitutes a 75 split if
you need to make a strategic decision by
my way calculation that's ten and a half
councils and ewe so I'm not sure what
that defaults to does it default to 10
or 11. I guess the only two issues that
jump out of that those slides for me
so we're happy to do that we'll just
move on and Aaron you can talk to the
submission
um I hope is is reasonably clear to
elect members but happy to take any
questions I think the key piece that I
would like to draw out is around the
transition timeline
um there's obviously a staged approach
moving forward now of different entities
coming online between 1 July 2024 and 30
June 2026
at the moment there is no Clarity around
where apart from apart from the Auckland
entity no Clarity around which entities
would come online when uh invercargill
city has given some clear Direction
around not committing to a time frame as
yet as to when it would like to
transition should three Waters go ahead
one of my concerns is that there isn't
anything in the current legislation that
requires consultation with individual
councils on when they would see
transition suiting them which means that
we may not have a say in when we would
like to transition and we may be pulled
Along by the decision of other councils
within our entity around when that
timing may be
that's probably the key piece that I'd
like to draw attention to apart from
that I'm happy to take any questions
so y'all come back to your ring just on
that one issue
here and I also have some issues around
that
um
we've been asked to consider from DIA
whether we would go early in the cycle
it's not a complex area they say for
otago southam but one of the issues for
me is we've already made the decision at
Council that we would not
um go early into into entity J until we
knew the outcome of the election
and we've got a few answers to some of
the things that we've been asking
clarification for in some cases several
years
what happens
if the other six councils and Ewe All
vote to go early are we caught up that
we have to then go and that's not
answered for me
and so I think our submission should say
that
if it doesn't already say it
um
ranging
um with my my first questions and I'll
start with these ones
um early on are around the statement
that this Council has to include three
Waters Service delivery and it's 2024
2034 ltp now that's the same as
ludicrous in the fact that we are we are
not going to be doing it and what's even
more ludicrous is the fact that under
the ACT
Council also has to prepare a 30-year
infrastructure plan now this is critical
obviously with the longevity of certain
types of infrastructure pipes and
everything that 30 years out is a more
practical way to look at stuff now my
question is do we
need to do the 30-year plan I mean I've
asked this of Dia in Dunedin last year
and the guy who went straight over his
head so
the 30-year plan now that's critical one
if we've got to do the ltp the 10-year
plan we surely must have to do the
30-year plan
So currently we've already got the
30-year plan prepared in draft so we
have pulled that together already
right and that is which for which 30
years are we talking about so going
forward into this next long-term plan
period okay so the 30-year plan starts
on 2024 July 2024 2024 and goes to 2015.
right so we are that's all worked on the
assumptions of the figures provided by
Dia
uh the assumptions are based on the
figures that staff had to pull together
to input into Dia's Asset Management
plan process
right and that still aligns with all our
budgets
those are the pieces that we're
currently working through because we
haven't finalized all of our budgets
obviously going into the next long-term
plan yet because obviously when we look
at the forecast and it's in the mayor's
submission of the future cost of three
Waters under this new entity
uh then we're talking
like big big big big big numbers and how
can this city with its current rate
forecast
achieve that
I mean we we in our ltp we've got a
rates forecast how can we deliver what
this
um says knowing that it's going to be
three times what we currently do
um how can we do it under our current
ltp rates forecast
it's the argument that Dia are making to
councils
um I think what we are saying is that
invercargill city is in a position where
we may I can't speak to whether or not
we'd be able to do it within our current
rates forecasts but that invercargill
City believes that it is in a strong
enough position both financially as well
as with its infrastructure that it could
continue to run its assets itself
oh you know this if we can but we won't
be able to because this tells us that if
the three Waters goes ahead we will not
be running our assets ourself we will be
doing it under entity J and so those
costs won't come to council although we
may bill for them they will be a cost
from The Entity to each individual
household in the community so it won't
form part of council's rate basis
ICC will be uh sending out the bills but
obviously are we responsible for
collecting the money if say someone
decides not to pay that is the
understanding yes and that is one of the
pieces that I see see as strongly spoken
against previously and reiterated in
this submission
just a couple of issues for me here
um on a submission um
the um the data that we're not referring
to
um refers to entity
um JB
roughly quarter million dollars a
quarter million in population base
for those around last term you'll have
heard the DIA and people from Scotland
and people from Tasmania saying the
ideal economy of scale for this type of
structure is about a million per entity
um we were getting down a little bit
below that and the when we had the four
entities South Island wasn't quite that
strong I think it was from memory about
1.1 million I think or might have been a
little bit less on there because the
turkey wire is a little bit smaller
um so I mean there's two other issues I
guess that go unresolved and all the
information we're getting from DIA one
where is the economy of scale
it's gone the other way just to give
individual councils the voice so that's
a significant impact it doesn't signaled
in the report and the other one was the
issue of Staffing and we talk in the
report about the drift of Staffing away
and some people might retire
again two and a half years ago one of
the issues that DIA
signal was there was a lack of water
engineers in the country and in fact
it's an international problem and at
that time they said they were going to
do some work with the universities to
try and up the intakes of people come in
being mindful this is a three-year
degree and I've heard nothing since him
so that's another worry that he even if
we go down to these entities will we
have the staff to be able to deliver
what's in in the global picture I guess
and the final thing for me because
um I'm finding two things for me is um
in in the slideshow that we're not
referring to it does refer to
councils plural that were not in the
entities and I don't know why they give
that comparison because we don't have a
choice to be outside it but if we were
outside our costs going forward for
water rates would be 9730
and we continue to get out of our
organization eighteen hundred and fifty
now I mean that's just an eye-watering
indiscrimacy and I still can't get an
answer to that and I don't think anybody
in frame has got an answer to that
and I guess the final thing is when we
say we want to uh we want to submit in
person to the Soviet committee who do
you think should be doing their
submission
so that was one of the items that we
wish to discuss at the end of this
process was whether or not yourself as
mayor would like to submit we have since
been advised that they won't be
in-person submissions Andrew correct me
if I'm wrong that they will be zoomed
submissions tomorrow afternoon
10 minutes each
I guess given that the primary issue
that's in here is the actual cost going
forward surely somebody to my right
would need to sit in on that Zoom as
well
one with the same
yep
any other questions about the submission
paper oh trash sorry
do we not have an option of pulling
right away from IntelliJ
there certainly seem to be railroading
railroading us and to conforming to
what's there and our cost and somehow
through the submission we have to make
sure again obviously that they are very
aware of that yep so um just give you a
quick backdrop to that
um
make sure I get this right so people are
not offended about two years ago and we
had the option to opt in and opt out
um and so all the councils opt-in
because it was money attached to that
but we had the discretion to opt out
um and the minister at meetings I was
there constantly reinforce that if you
think invercargills can be better off
being out then you there's no reason why
you can't stand alone
pregnancy
then I read the national papers that
seemed about
three months earlier than that cabinet
made a decision that they're going to
take away that provision so we're we're
all in whether we liked it or not
and we've never had an option to be out
unfortunately
so um we keep banging a hit against the
wall but
I think there wouldn't be too many
people in the infrastructure world and
invercargill that would if we had a
choice we'd still be up
yeah ringing
um I'll just check it in now we've got
can there be a grammar correction in in
paragraph 13 of your of the submission
it's just uh it reads this is also not
be feasible and it sort of sounds a bit
Shakespeare's yeah we can correct that
thank you yeah yeah yeah and I just want
to talk about it talks about better off
and we're self-funding now and results I
mean basically it boils down to October
if we have a change of government we're
better off and if we don't we're worse
off I mean that's basically what better
off where itself means
I think Michael day will correct me if
I'm wrong but there were two sets of
fundings available one the government's
been committed to all the way through
and one they withdrew recently
and so yeah and I just note that the one
that has been committed to the concern
raised here is that through changes in
the bill which we're hoping are an error
um that that committed funding that the
government's already committed to
appears to have been removed from the
legislation yeah
so we just want to ensure that that's an
error but there were two there were two
levels where they were there that's
right yeah so you're talking about the
one that we think is still there that's
right correct yeah thank you
oh Michael
yeah yourself Mia um just to clarify on
that no no worse off um and better of
funding uh From perspective of the
better off funding that was removed as
part of the this particular bill for the
second phase so that was splitting too
um there was church one entrance two
church one has been allocated and that
remains
um for those councils who have not yet
drawn down on it still remains in place
but for tranche 2 that has been removed
um because the cost of the transitions
uh transitioned for 10 entities is
higher than four so the additional
funding is required to be able to do the
transitional cost was the information
that had been provided to CES
okay
any further discussions
it's just a select correction Mr
spelling of your name at the bottom the
submission is increased yeah I don't
take offense to that it caught many
things
extreme apologies for missing this
oh deeply heard yeah
we'll blame having to pull submissions
together
any further discussion around
oh sorry Ria yes that's okay I'm just um
coming back to Aaron's or your question
earlier of um who would be required to
submit the submission to the panel and
that that's requiring a zoom attendance
um in my head I'm thinking you and your
CE yeah
I would think so too much technical
stuff around that 1800 that I can't
explain
yeah
but look let's let's not Beyond any
Cloud this this is just a an excise of
futility it's going the way it's going
and we just had to accept that
unfortunately
any disc I further discussion with
Michael
throw yourself me I would note that the
NTU is strategically placed the Roadshow
um of all of those slides that we will
be discussing at the same time as the
submissions
yep
foreign
and it may be that officers are
reluctant to answer this for the reasons
they've previously given
but we have seen an EP per
um uh estimated
um
future cost
to under cargo repairs of about 4 500
and unfortunately because I'm a zoom
accountable papers they don't see the
precise number but it's a bad order
compared to the officer's calculation of
around eighteen hundred dollars
can I just clarify that they are
absolutely like for like that in fact
under three Waters
um I'll say rate peers but I know it's
through the rates exactly but they will
pay more than double
under the proposed system
um what they would do if we had been
allowed to carry on our own and I said
that they may not wish to answer that
question so I mean I'm presuming that
they are actually like the late
comparisons 1800 if we go on our own
four thousand five hundred approximately
if we get dragged in this nightmare yeah
so before Michael does give you that
view of the world
um
that paragraph you're referring to says
the recently released 1080 modeling
estimates average household so I'm
assuming that's average right across all
10 entities is 4439
and my my view of that is that when you
look at the original figures we got
um
Auckland over the next 10 years is
actually not going up at all
and so when you start talking about
National averages and you're combining
all 10 entities that may not be the
impact for us locally because if
auckland's not going up
um we might be going up by a larger
amount than that but I'll get Michael
day two
comment on it thank you through yourself
Mia um look I'm going to put a caveat
around both numbers
um both numbers were prepared on
information that was pre uh the impact
of inflat the significant rise in
inflation so both numbers I I would say
are both wrong
um ours will be over certain magnitude
but it'll they'll both would both move
in respect of are they comparable do
they have the same information in them
absolutely not
um we actually our our 1850 original
number was based on what we believed we
needed to spend in relation to our
infrastructure and the the Assumption
that's been used for the NTU numbers as
this is previous information distributed
I can provide
um that information was based off an
average in relation to
what a population of this size would
need to spend in relation to its capital
investment based on the Scottish model
so it wasn't particularly relevant to
what we needed to spend or the condition
of our Network Etc from an invercargill
perspective so are they comparable
absolutely not will that be the cost who
knows from that perspective the other
side is the 1850 didn't assume that we
would get significant savings because we
weren't combining into different
entities the other one assumes the level
of savings to get to that figure as well
so it's likely to be
I would I would estimate likely to be
slightly higher but we don't know what's
included in in that particular number it
is an estimate averaged across the whole
country
thank you
and I mean I will take that I'll take
that
mirrors being you know sort of Prima
facing it's 1850 versus 4 500 but the
numbers may be a little bit different
because the detail in terms of how the
numbers are made up
um the modeling is different but it's
difficult to see them coming you know
much closer together as a consequence of
you know fiddling at the edges so I mean
and the model I'll have in my head is
1850 versus 4 500 and I think The
4400 and I think the people that are
watching this livestream that's probably
the number that they need to take away
their head
yep and as I said before
um Auckland being the biggest entity of
the lot well Auckland and North Auckland
um has current rates about 800 a year
which is very similar to what we have
and 10 years from now they're not
focused focused
forecast to increase it all and you'd
have to ask yourself why that is
and and it's my view having said in on
this for three years now the rationale
for that is they've got water meters
so they have economy of scale and they
have water meters and you won't have
heard Dia talk about water meters at all
in the last two and a half years
um but they are the way forward
because it allows individual households
to make a choice on how much water they
use just as we do with power at the
moment but they're highly controversial
because there are winners and losers so
they just don't want to talk about it
but we do need them some are online but
nobody will talk about that
because that then allows an individual
household to cut their cloth accordingly
if they want to
keep that pressure off
and it's actually quite good because
less less watering at the front end
means less that you have to treat out
the other end as well
so yeah
any other questions yeah rangi
um look to me to me this whole
project is about credibility starting
from day one even going back to 2017
when infrastructure New Zealand took a
group of delegates over to visit the
Scotland
um
and the whole thing was about the
economy of scale now the first proposal
was with four entities
and that delivered a supposedly a
massive economy of scale and it showed
in the figures where ours was there
around the 1800 mark their proposal was
about 2 300 or 2400.
now after a bit of pushback
they've now created the 10 entity
um model and the predictions per
household have gone through the roof now
seriously if you had if there was any
credibility to the proposal you would
not budge you just say look it can only
work this way and the fact that there's
been a compromise to try and pacify uh
various political uh
um sort of yelling and shouting then
that there is no credibility sorry the
the model either works whether it's
economy or scale or it doesn't you
either do it or you don't properly so
the fact we've got a cop out now of of a
hybrid we don't even know what it is
um and and if you want to compare it to
how the Polytech uh reform went then
that's a great example of where this is
probably going to go
so
that really undermines the whole thing
to me sorry if that's stuck with the
four entity thing at least you would
have known they were sincere in their
modeling
um so no sorry I'll come back here
Leslie
um and that's been my reflection as well
um they've taken us to more entities as
opposed to less even though the advice
that we got from Morrison Lowe on
invercargill and The Wider picture in
New Zealand and from the experts that
came from Melbourne and from Tasmania
was that we were fairly marginal in the
South Island for that economy of scale
um they've gone the other way just
purely to give each Council a boat at
the table where in fact
and just just accepted that somebody
from Dunedin might have represent us
because at the end of the day we're here
for the the cost of water that's the
cost and the quality of water
um and and we've lost all of that
because the cost is going to go through
the roof correct no and and look and
like you've heard me talk before are you
scratching head Ria
H
um and the other issue is the issue that
came out of the Elgin conference lgnz
conference in Queenstown recently about
what happens when the debt transfers
across in otagos album and we then start
paying it
share of the debt that's currently
sitting in Queenstown it's an
eye-watering amount compared to what
we've got here but we will pay for that
so we are very much going away from the
invercargill from invercargill and we're
going very much into
otago South and we would just be one
player on it in the field loosely
thank you Mr Mia I'm not sure what the
purpose of the last couple of um
were except to make political statements
because as far as I'm concerned what
we're discussing is a submission to a
draft bill
in the reality of what's in the
submission what we have before us
is a 10 entity proposal and our
submission is commenting on that
11 and 12 of their submission have gone
quite deeply into the affordability of
the reforms have pointed out that the
move has been from four to ten entities
and then have tried to deal with that
reality I'm not sure why there's any
going back in the history
of the original four entity proposal at
this stage when the submission we're
making is on a 10 entity proposal so
let's let's get real we're discussing
the submission which is due in tomorrow
and whether or not we're comfortable
with it as a submission
so on the terms in which it's written as
a submission and what it is submitting
about
it's a reasonable submission that
encompasses the invercargill city
council views yeah
before I come to your area
um and I accept that but again I've
given some license to counselors who
wish to express their concerns about the
whole package development in the last
three or four years including myself
because really what other options have
we had to discuss it in a way that the
community can actually hear what we
think on this issue we've been very much
silenced by the government and by D.A
Ria uh thank you Mr Mia
um
on reflection I do think that you have
some council members that perhaps aren't
aware of that background so that is
quite helpful to show um the information
in short form
so in the submission I'd like to go to
0.7
.8 and 11.
in 13 but I want to start with 13 if I'm
a Aaron with that information that
you've provided to us
what I want to be clear it on is should
we have an unfortunate incident that
um
um we're injury J and something happens
with the
uh water that becomes contaminated who
is going to be responsible for that
under this act
because it looks like we are as it sits
out in point 13 that we are responsible
for collecting and administrating and
transferring funds on behalf of the
water services entity Jay so let me add
to that because I know the answer to
this because I've raised as executive
issue is that when we get into an entity
regardless of the size of the entity one
of the issues for the entity will be the
priority of their funding going forward
what they will invest in so the question
I asked D.A about two and a half three
years ago was look given because we are
a large entity then given the growth and
so on given the growth in Queenstown
Lakes District given the climate change
issues in South Dunedin where will our
need for a second water supply which is
what we're alluding to here because
we've only got one and we're one of the
only provincial cities in the country
that only has one Supply
where will that sit well that's where
will that sit in the priority and the
answer was that will be decided by the
incoming entity and so there is that
issue about you know where does a
liability set will it'll sit with the
entity but that doesn't necessarily mean
it'll resolve our problem
I guess my
um attention
to that particular point is that
regardless of what um we've gone through
and others have gone through my concern
is who ultimately will be held
responsible given the fact that there is
this cloudy area of which Acts skip
across a health issue
so sorry what the legislation has um
done quite quite clearly I would suggest
is to remove that responsibility
um post-transition from local
authorities across to those water
services entities what remains with
local authorities is a
ability for us to be mandated to assist
the entity with administrative type
functions and that's where you'll hear
talk of service level agreements being
entered into with the various different
authorities until such time as the new
entities have those administrative back
office functions in place within within
each of their own entities
obviously some of the details still
being worked through but I think the
risk to local authorities of still being
held responsible for a public health
outbreak for example
um is pretty unlikely
okay and I guess the final reflection
I'll have for you here is that um
is it and third thing that also talks
about the billing which is the admin
functions so reasonable from my
perspective and Michael will have the
more more specific details on it but the
moment we jump into bed with the other
councils and entity D our rates will go
through the roof at one rate and we're
still collecting them under a service
level agreement which is all very well
so where do you think the unease will be
it won't be with the entity that
probably is based in Dunedin they'll
come in because they'll be collected
alongside all our other rates even
though we will separate them out they'll
be right here and then the next question
will be is if you knew this was coming
why didn't you do something about it
so just Sigma hopefully it won't be in
my time
uh is there any way that we can
um
be a bit more
statement in here to point that fact out
um that we will be
as amir's just said
um
raising the rates to our Council stuck
in the process of who's clicked in one
as many as any can you think any other
way that we can strengthen up that
statement to put an effect that you know
we would be at a disadvantage
I can help me with that local government
New Zealand has done some face-to-face
at some of the conferences about this
with the DIA and with the minister
when you raise the current Minister and
say look we don't want to be collecting
what might be a very steep incline the
moment we get that debt servicing that's
going to really kick in for us because
we we don't have that level of debt
servicing at the moment because our debt
is very low
um let's see about 10 of what Queenstown
is and so um but there was they just say
they don't have the mechanism the people
on the ground the structure to be able
to collect that they need us to collect
it for the first
I think you use the word medium term so
whatever that means Leslie I was
supposed to say in terms of addressing
that
um there's a statement there that talks
about Council opposing being compelled
to collect revenue for a service we no
longer control and deliver partly
because it will exacerbate public
confusion about who is accountable for
water services we could add on to that
um particularly given the likely
increasing costs that the community will
face in this space I think that's that's
a good yeah
you want us to further discussion Maria
uh
uh what was it I'll come back to that I
was going to add something to him okay
Leslie
Aaron's actually answered what I was
going to say because I was going to say
that was the perfect sentiments to add
something to since we're already saying
we're opposing it and why but Aaron's
already covered that
back to you Ria if you
um
sorry Mister I've lost my train of
thought with those bullet points there
okay
I mean if all else files you can always
get into Aaron's here at low stage yeah
with it have a quick whisper so one of
the other things is when we verbally go
to submit to the panel yeah mostly As
you know
um this local submissions are taken as
read I think it would be a good
um process to give them a wee bit of a
side swing would be to
um strategize and how you
um talk about the points here
um and at home that we're really not
comfortable with being forced into this
position
okay
any other discussions
bring them with somebody like to move
the final recommendation then which was
to prove the attached Council submission
to the water services Bill Amendment
bill
Barry
Darren thank you any further discussion
on that
all in favor
carried
thank you for your time this morning and
the link that is taken
give you an update after we're here
tomorrow
oh no we're just gonna do the workshop